welcome back everyone I am here with
Benjamin Bugg who just won the
Armageddon two Armageddon to clinch the
title for group a so congratulations
Benjamin how do you feel uh yeah it
feels amazing uh yeah yeah it feels
amazing feels great of course the wind
event
um yeah I knew it was not gonna be easy
and uh I felt like my main competitor
was going to be Savion I've actually
also played him in the World Cup in 2021
and the match it also went down to the
wire so it feels great to get my uh
revenge and uh yeah I feel it feels
great to win the vent overall
draws and then you want two games in a
row and you played one of the probably
the best games of the tournament as you
described it the perfect game where you
had that amazing preparation and then
you won that Bishop versus night
position and then today you decided to
make a quick draw
um where you're hoping you'd go into tie
breaks did you think you had a better
chance or why didn't you wanna
try beating your opponent yeah it's a
good question so yeah I felt like
um I I just kind of wanted to get the
tournament over with I felt like I
played a good event I didn't wanted to
to spoil it in the last round and I
figured okay in the in the tie break
I'll I'll get my chances
um of course I knew that a lot of people
could join for a tie break uh up to six
people that ended up being five and I
wasn't even sure what the format was
gonna be but yeah my I figured okay I I
just wanted to log in share it first and
a good event
um and yeah that was basically my my
thought process going in into the game
like I just didn't want to take big
risks into going into this uh this game
and um yeah he ended up playing very
solidly and so yeah and then we went for
this repetition and I was I was fine
with it so I don't necessarily have any
real regrets well not after this right
not after this of course but even after
the game even when I saw many people
winning I I kind of regretted not
winning yesterday against Mishra that
was a little bit uh annoying because I
felt like that like I had great chances
to win that game and if I win that game
I think I have great chances to win the
event
um
but yeah today I I felt like just just
playing it solid and we'll see what
happens in a tour break so when you
whenever you didn't think he would win
with the black pieces right it was
probably a thought process so what kind
of realistically what were you expecting
because it's hard to expect so many
players to win and have this huge tie
break right yeah so by the time I finish
my game I thought that well first I
thought Christopher you was a bit worse
and then he got a better position and
then he blundered uh so so yeah when he
got a better position I was a little bit
worried I was I was saying like oh I
hope he doesn't uh win and just win
event overall and then he blunted and of
course it's very important for him but I
was happy to see it
um and uh yeah it was I I thought
there's a good chance that at least one
player would join like two you you never
know
um but I thought that there would be a
good chance we would play Ty break with
four players but yeah I've never had
I've never had an event where there's a
five-way tie for first and five out of
nine wins you the event
it's like half of the tournament times
for first place yeah this was a very
tightly contested uh tournament and
let's talk about this Armageddon so in
your first uh game so you actually got
seated into the next round because of
your good tie break so you didn't play
the first game and uh you chose to play
White and you actually chose to play
White in both games so why did you
choose to play white instead of getting
the droughts
I feel like it's just a little bit
easier to play with why you have an
extra minute on the clock which
definitely counts for something and you
get the white pieces and I feel with why
you know I'm just going to go all out
and try to play quickly try to put as
much pressure as possible whereas with
black you can easily start hesitating
like should I play solid should I play
for the win uh so I feel like it's in a
way easier to play with white like you
know what you have to do and I I feel
like one minute is definitely a
significant Advantage especially over
the board when you play online you know
you can make up with pre-moves at the
end but over the board if you have uh 10
seconds against the 30 you're just gonna
lose and
like white has a huge Advantage right
because the time is so little so at
which point do you think that becomes a
little more even with the time
difference it's a very good question so
I think at World Cups they often have
the time control where y gets five
minutes and black gets four minutes but
there is two seconds of increment after
move 60. so I asked Mike whether there
was an increment at any point during the
game and he said no so then I knew okay
I'm just gonna pick uh pick white
um I think maybe something like six
versus five is around even but I think
five versus four white should definitely
have an advantage so you think this
increment makes a huge difference
because we had these conversation during
last year American Cup and Levin was
very insistent about this increment
because he thought at some point it's
just not just anymore because we said we
see these games right the piece is
rolling and so you think without
increment you just always choose white
in the same control I think five versus
four you you should pick white yeah so
let's quickly talk about your game so
they were very quick games I don't know
how much
because I know it's pure adrenaline so
in this first game
uh so the position let's go to this
bishop end game so at this point when
all of this this A5 happens how are you
feeling here I wasn't too happy here
like I'm still up like 30 or 20 seconds
on the clock but
um it's it's difficult to win and uh or
yeah I mean he's just completely fine so
it's very difficult to to win I wasn't
too happy here but uh at some point he
and he he kept spending time
and yeah if we keep going so I thought
like here I'm definitely a favorite or I
don't know if I was a favorite to lose
but I mean I still have I still have the
time which always counts for something
so I wasn't too happy here but at some
point okay so A4 I got my Pana but he he
just stops I mean I still have like 20
seconds on the clock which is definitely
something I go King up A3 king of King
E7
um the king of five he takes Bishop C3 I
mean right around here so Bishop D3 E4 I
feel like it cannot be good for me but
as you see I have one minute and 13
seconds he's got 50 seconds and it's not
clear to me how he's gonna promote the
pawn like he can go Bishop B1 and A2 but
my plan my moves are very easy I go King
G6 I take on G7 and at the in the worst
case I can give one of my Bishops
um take all his King side pawns hope for
summing and and of course I always have
the time so
I wasn't necessarily too concerned here
and then of course when he played King
E6 he blundered upon yeah and then I
think it's just over because I'm up uh
20 seconds and it's King side just
collapses so this is just over yeah this
was a real
and he went Bishop A6 because you know
yeah Bishop V6 all of a sudden and then
he found I feel like kind of fun with
your Basics and then King D6 so it's
pretty heartbreaking to see because you
know he just played so hard this whole
game and
and he also played such a long game to
qualify to this tie break so it was just
really amazing to see him fight so hard
and as you mentioned the time Advantage
was really big and in your second game
you also chose White against Sam so and
you didn't play anything too theoretical
right you just well this line has some
has some Venom to it and I always see uh
Hikaru play this online so that was kind
of my uh inspiration going into the game
and like you know why keeps the pieces
on the board it's a little bit easier to
play for white and I think like right
around here after Bishop B7 and the good
thing was I think after E3 on the second
move like I got the same thing at least
four for a little bit whereas he's super
booked up and that gave me an edge on
the clock like I think very quickly it
was not a one minute but like one minute
or 30 seconds one minute and 20 seconds
and that that's definitely uh what you
want so I was happy with what I got out
of the opening
um yeah so here yeah it all looks pretty
good I go E4 Rook C8 Rook fe1 perhaps at
some point I just have to go E5 you know
kick the Knight away and yeah again like
if you look at the clock I'm up like
more than a minute so a minute and 10
seconds uh but to me it'll look good to
after Queen B6 to take on D5 but yeah
yeah so he takes I think all of this is
fine 24 G6 C4 oh this looks good take
take and the one thing though is that I
took a long time for e-takes D5 and
again like I'm still up on the clock
yeah like 30 seconds 30 seconds like you
shouldn't like I was talking with a
friend before the game and he told me
like never spend a minute in an
Armageddon game a minute this year
Advantage right yeah I just found it but
of course the so were you considering E5
I wasn't really considering E5 like I
like the fact that I have my two Bishops
on the on the diagonal so I like this
idea of takes and queen E4 and uh it's
kind of awkward for him to protect and
yeah I saw C4 so he takes Queen d8 yeah
all of this looks really good and then
uh when he played Bishop F6 I initially
missed it after it takes takes I can't
go Knight D6 because it was 93.
but I still like my position like
um after Rook C1
I think I always have some some pressure
but yeah my time Advantage was dwindling
here like here I'm up like 30 seconds
and he he gets a fine position Baroque
fd8 looks pretty logical Bishop of one I
thought was a good move 97
I don't know if 95 was good but I mean I
still have some pressure but but again
like I don't have as much of an edge on
the clock anymore
um and then he got he got his pieces
pretty active so 95 985 Queen E3 so he
took and uh 55 I win 96 so he took Queen
B2
maybe I think like at some point I
should just take the pawn on A6
um and I don't know it's
that's definitely the difference between
like classical and Blitz like in a
classical game you just calculate in the
Blitz game you're like well you know
maybe he will start creating some
threats or I don't know like you want to
keep some sort of control but of course
that's uh that's difficult
so he went uh yeah there nice this just
looks so nice for you because your kid
looks so safe and yeah this Knight on C5
is just beautiful yes another five but
yeah around here time around here was
time was even so that was definitely a
bit concerning
um but okay Queen C3 I thought the end
game should be good for me then Rook D1
I I think I'm still better here like I
have I have the advantage on the board
but of course I'd like to have both like
the advantage on the clock and on on the
board so what happens if you take this
Knight H4 um yeah I'm just I'm just
asking for something to happen like
that's and I thought okay rookie one at
least I pin his Bishop so it's going to
be difficult for him to unleash some
sort of tactic human worksheet and queen
E5 to me looks very pleasant and I
already saw this idea of 97 to F6 but
again like time is even so pretty much
anything can happen but then you played
A5 quickly I played Knight D7 and I
think here he's just in a world of
trouble like Knight F6 is a major major
threat if he ever goes like King h8 I
take on D5 when or like 94. so already I
I didn't see move from and here he was
thinking for a long time I don't know
how much how long yeah he spent almost a
minute he spent almost a minute and that
pretty much says so yeah after 97 I
think it's just over at least
practically especially after he took so
long did you already at the board did
you feel like you have this in the game
or you were just still okay I mean I
thought like oh this this is looking
really good but of course you can never
you can never relax you should you know
stay focused till the very end um but I
mean Knight F6 is coming like if you
have this in a Blitz game you win this
like 99 of the time
um but he plays there Knight of six
takes stakes and yeah here I I pretty
much knew it was over like I'm up
um 30 seconds I have that a pawn running
down the board and I was pretty happy
with how I converted the game I thought
after Bishop B3 G4 was super accurate
like the Knight has to move and here all
of his pieces are loose so that's also
another thing for him like it's very
difficult for him not to drop more
material if he moves to neither of them
Queen B7 and all of his stuff is hanging
and then oh yeah just to take every
single piece yeah and Rook C3 or yeah
The Rook C3 I can just take the knife
and never mind okay so yeah Rook C6 and
I just push the pawn and and yeah on top
of that he had no time so I like to hear
how he took the bishop I appreciated
this a lot because this Knight is just
so bad just take the bishop yeah and
with one minute against 19 seconds and
then you picked up another piece and
those game over yeah this was a very
dominant performance by you and you do
win clear first place picking up six
thousand dollars so there is no time for
you this was a big money round uh so
what is next for you I don't know yet
um it's a good question so yeah I don't
play a whole lot over the board anymore
but this event definitely uh got me you
know fired up again I wanna I wanna play
more but it's kind of it's kind of funny
like like you said I lost the first
round and then the second round I also
played terrible and I'm thinking to
myself like okay what am I why am I
playing this tournament but starting
from round three I I got into it I felt
like I played good chess and I knew
eventually my chances are going to come
and I I took them
um my next tournament I don't know like
over the summer there will be the Dutch
Champion uh Dutch Championship since
I've never won it I definitely want to
win it at least one time you know my
career before I uh retire uh so yeah
that's definitely on uh on my radar for
the rest I I don't know like oh there's
these World Cup
unfortunately I I didn't qualify like I
didn't play the European championship
and that was my one chance to to qualify
so
um hey maybe fetus watching you can't
give me uh can give me a wild card
um but yeah no I I definitely want to
play more uh chess again I want to try
to push for the top 100 try to push for
26.50 I think it's definitely possible
and beyond that of course it's it's not
going to be easy but I I definitely want
to want to play more uh over the board
chess and shift my focus a little bit
more to that you know I feel like
cycle of chosen you're not a
professional
play and you're like you know what chess
is so hard then you have one good
tournament and then you get so inspired
and then you start playing again and
then you play badly and then you're like
no no no no well often often what
happens to people is that they play a
lot and they're like oh this is so
tiring this is stressful and uh and then
they start missing it right and then
they play and they're like oh this is so
difficult and they go back into
retirement
um but yeah I definitely have been
missing it every time like there's a big
event going on like tat is still chess
I'm kind of like I kind of wish I was
there so now I'm here again and yeah I
think
also for for myself like with every
event I play I feel like there's always
uh something I learned not just from
playing but also the all the the
preparation that's the great thing about
these events because a lot of these
tournaments in the US you play two
rounds a day and you know you you wake
up you prepare some lining you go go and
play and then before you know it like
you're around your game finishes you
have to eat something and you play again
but with these kind of events I feel
like it definitely gives players to push
their game to the next level so that's
why I think it's great for uh players
like Mishra or or Christopher you who
are still very very young to to play in
these or and all the other prodigies in
the in the B group as well
um so I think these events um are great
and yeah maybe I'll I'll play in the
Summer Classic as well yeah I mean I
agree with you because I think there's a
grading group that
that's difficult and if you're not
playing a lot what are you doing are you
streaming more you're teaching uh yeah
I'm streaming I'm streaming I'm teaching
I put all my lessons on hold during this
event so you know sorry to my uh to my
students I'll I'll pick up again
um yeah probably from from tomorrow
um and yeah I think I'll do a stream
tonight to to celebrate
um besides that they're they're having
these Olympic Esports Olympic online
Olympic Esports qualifiers which started
today I think there's also
um some tomorrow so I think I'll play in
those uh as well
um so yeah lots of uh lots of Chess um
coming up online tests mostly well
that's the luck to you
situation on winning this event I hope
for you to play more over the board and
looking forward to seeing you here more
and that was the winner of group a
Benjamin Bach who won